vivo prima dotta 300 euro dai cani
cosa fai un caffè per tutto il solo dato
lo faccio subito cioè impegni sono
importanti improrogabili non fra tre ore
9 media center subito solo per questa
volta non già che ci sei scuso di
scogliere portare via la tazzina di ieri
quest'anno
[Musica]
ecco quasi non vorrei sembrare scortese
però io ho mandato la comanda cinque
minuti fa dico che hai fatto tutto
questo tempo ho fatto un ritardo non
deve né la prosopopea di pensare che due
minuti di ritardo non siano niente ho
sbagliato ecco qua sono passati diversi
mesi dalla mia ultima appropriazione
indebita e giuste un rincarare la dose
ed oggi su un canale da un milione totti
scritti o la giusta esposizione
mediatica parlo di un'esposizione
mediatica agis esposizione mediatica in
controcampo esposizione mediatica che
sotto il letto lamu e sono pronto a
mettere a ferro e fuoco il canale tv e
walsh ma avrò bisogno dell'aiuto di una
certa nuno svegliati bambino mio per
appropriazione indebita
sting razzi si mangia che cosa andremo a
fare oggi allora praticamente a un amico
che aspetta
devo risalire su casa per un grande
menticavo un'esposizione un amico che è
un pezzo di pane di uomo un amico pezzo
di pane praticamente questo pane si
sveglia tutte le mattine alle 3 di notte
va a napoli con il suo furgoncino prende
la mozzarella di bufala appena fatta
calda di giornata per il venezia un
neopatentato la riporta a roma e che
c'entro io faccio l'ordine che un pane
amicolo intercetto mozzarella di bufala
campana casse che ci hanno ridotto il
vero che ho cambiato varie belle ben
altri commesse
un appassionato cazzo di vetro allo
sfascio giudici hanno divertito cioè
quando di dottor vetro interventi sempre
in un rapinatore
la macchina non è stata mai riparata
enrico ha speso più di nastro e sacchi
della spazzatura vetri rimasti dentro la
macchina come l'abbiamo lasciata è un
tema che viene usata regolarmente
consigliata pure per il sesso perché
allungarsi quando hai il telecomando a
portata che tra l'altro non apre il
finestrino del guidatore è disagiati che
quando mai state dentro e così fu subito
gravato il sacro graal questi cartoni
meridie del pana le mozzarelle non
voleva farmi spostare la macchina col
siero delle mozzarelle in una parola
pane pane come al solito si riserva 43
mezzo 1 stiamo raggiungendo gianluigi e
che è andato al passo di pal pezzo di
pane a prendere la bufala siamo ragazzi
ma ecco tutte le televisioni di bufale
seguitemi
il 19 febbraio
[Musica]
un cazzo di niente ma non è sempre
quello lì ma un vetro con tremila lire
il mio parere è ancora calda senti la la
nostra bufala ma è sempre calda la
nostra bufala proprio ruolo
sei d'accordo certo per legge qualche
problemino ma sul vetro prova di vedere
eseguite verificarlo in dentro se no non
si chiudesse di faletti qui sono tornata
tornando via ma anche la nostra quello
che fai cagare giornale
ma vediamo 10 kg di bucarest e siliquini
di madagascar maschi al tavolo portato
con me nostra
tu sei complice la pratica detto che ho
un amico un pane ho capito non lasceremo
il contatto dell'amico definisce che è
paese ha unito ma la mostra di bufale in
inverno o problemi che la notte del 6 e
le buche non pascolano e quindi non è
comunque la primaverile quindi acqua
calda la vasca da bagno ecc e la
buttiamo dentro una ragazzina guarda
guarda una forbice che capello il
polistirolo comunque che se io stavo
pulendo fino a 2 secondi fa tutta casa e
faccio un culo così volere questo antico
aveva scherzato in faccia triste dato
schiaffo si capisce anche come sei
sessualmente parlando sessualmente
parlando al momento una vita abbiamo la
mozione alzatevi non bisogna essere
troppo delicati non mi capisci mattina
tre ore di vita
metti sentito invito a guardare una mega
busta arrivata morta in quella sorprese
non finiscono fratello a voce la
sorpresa anche questa vino cibo prodotto
da un mio amico e tulot in azione cambia
colore perché c'è la micro bucce perché
vivo ferro mal di testa 0 soffitti
binoche io son morto e il vino è l'unica
cosa che rimane viva e cosa dietro
l'orecchio a dentro la vasca papu papa
fosse licenziate ma che so studiati per
cassano che mangiare era la ciotola di
culto galleggiano qua dentro
piove calde meglio il latte
nell'antichità si faceva il bagno
a mio padre
che schifo gli odori selvaggio ma viene
punito lotta si fa conoscere la super
udinese
siamo quattro concorrenti tre tipi di
mozzarelle ho creato poc'anzi una
tabella g concorrenti i nomi possono
essere cambiati quando si ciuccia una
mozzarella si segna a seconda di quella
che abbiamo mangiato tre fondi e dentro
l'acqua calda
riprende vita vita vita questo è tutta
finta che sia chiaro non segnate le cose
degli altri o disegnate più linee ma
ancor prima di iniziare
se l'ha fatto per terra questo siano che
fa un pool sopravento mi dovrebbe
ringraziare per quello che ho portato io
ho pulito stamattina a casa ieri sera ho
fatto tutti i sanitari la cucina voi
ringrazieresti vostro fratello che si fa
la doccia col siena in mezzo al bagno e
soprattutto passa con le sue scarpe di
merda dove è appena passato il modulo
della sveglia di epico guarda non voglio
sapere comunque ho così a fare in culo e
di là
nessuno si vuole chiamare il gangster
del fiordilatte trovare un nome
cleopatra professore suo look da chi lo
vota e che solamente una parrucca nasti
le bufale rowe il trasformista
terzo ma non ultimo da un cambio ma
cazzo di niente come cazzo di exter del
fiordilatte un brindisi ghedini e vivo
cattivo pino vivo ed una a una curiosità
adesso chi è che a dicembre ha guidato
il mio scooter
io sono arrivate la bellezza di tre
multe a carico comunicatore ma c'è
scritto ci lasciano certo è sempre lo
stesso punto e io pago
ma questo importante paese sono partiti
che non mi parve separate le multe si
ghiaccia e delle nostre c'è 1 euro di
multa cento ora lasciami vivere la mia
vita comune col rosso vivo è eccezionale
hai la possibilità o ripagarla subito al
73 euro e 50 t mentre saliamo quasi
accede cosa scegliere andiamo a mangiare
evvai
no
certo che belle consistenza come fa con
le mani lanciate che schermo è
abominevole una roba così da è un succo
della coscia
buona la sezione ragazzi il bagnetto non
servono mi attivai sto giocando anch'io
ne vai
[Musica]
[Risate]
sta scolando sono molto interessanti
declamerà c'è nella memoria
[Applauso]
ma crescita perché non avete capito per
cos'è una casa mi state sgocciolando
ovunque
esattamente la funzione di una palla di
gomma che vi siete mangiati voi
che schifo e poi un primo antonio questa
è la tecnica che dico vorrei presentarla
posto può e poi non deve venire mai
quando mangi il coso sotto quello di
rimettere a terra va bene che questo può
essere motivo di marchi brevetti che
dice berlusconi io non sto godendo
questa mostra vecchio sfondi due secondi
costose mano è buona
intanto meccanico buoni mattino notare
piatto nella nella tabella ascari schifo
perché ci sono preda di una sezione
piero la prendiamo una bilancia ma qui
nella ricca di rimandi classifica che
cosa nasce da serena terranno luglio
sarà una gara di sci botte e c'era il
secondo che stava accanto a me che se
stanno bene cosa amico cade
rovinosamente a rischio di farsi male e
quello che secondo
[Applauso]
e poi così all in one abituali non è
caduto silenzio perché è caduto male e
io locali di una cosa che per vincere
non sempre devi essere più forte basta
[Applauso]
poi tutti quanti che scrivete grande
gabriele che la canzone è stata non ci
guardano a noi di 525 punti modo
schifoso arriva una questi fa nel por
chile mierda schifo un'altissima
fastidio
dei dieci chili di bufala così ho
buonissimi canapa giovani possano
danneggiare quante 81 poter fare solo
con i test sono il culo se continui a
buttare nel polo abiti nella regione
campana aperto cioè regoli riconoscere
perché non ti basta stare in allerta per
i campani con un altro che si guarda a
potenza un altro chilo di mozzarella nel
culo vale come che ti regalerò una multa
[Applauso]
beh
potrebbe andare io faccio il danno e poi
tu pulisce e anche tu nei fatti ma non
li vedi perché io sto continuando a
pulire mi aiutate io so manger skeletron
la parte interessante grazie alla gamba
fantasia
adesso che mandava
gianmarco c'è ma si vede che il più
delle volte quando si diventa c'è
qualcuno dietro il weekend non si
diverte ma dove ieri è il momento della
terzina zero perché voglio essere
attento alle calorie una mozzarella da
250 grammi contiene 616 chi locali e
cioè il fabbisogno giornaliero di che
oggi domani arriverà uccello cosa
accadrà se la coppia migliore fattura
lettura sto arrivando a ragazze e
ragazzi che questo non è
è piacevole vedere ma questo non
esistono che aiuti gli stati della sera
il paniere e quant'altro cibo per un
altro montana servirebbe un buon
esercizio di stato cioè colui che ha
definito ragazzi fate schifo ragazzi
intrattenimento di intrattenimento per
bambini di 14 anni darci un verdetto dai
un attimo stava facendo dei calcoli
siamo veramente arrivati agli sgoccioli
di questa sfida cleopatra si classifica
quarto con 400 quindi bartolo 104 100
grammi ieri
1000 kg calorie ingerite al terzo posto
giancarlo jean caio si porta a casa dei
ragazzi un chilo di sono un fan solo un
chilo e 2.500 il vincitore del contest
10 kg di mozzarella o valeri
trasformisti un chilo e mezzo con dischi
fa la carezza dell'assunzione di 3.750
kcal da 3700 59.050 si paga cari ed e
sentono il secondo secondo posto c'è il
gangster di ordinate un chilo e 250 e
3000 125 kg e non sentirle ecco gabriele
hai la fortuna di mettermi a posto tutta
casa perché se il primo di distruggere i
ragazzi di mister e mangiano di
cioccolato ma fate schifo fondato basta
continuava la prendono e tanto citata
per bene dobbiamo il fegato 2021 visions
anche questa proiezione indebita in
volta al suo termine perché non importa
quanta bufala maggi l'importante è che
quello più bravo di te siro ragazzi il
video è giunto al termine ci siamo
divertiti tantissimo abbiamo mangiato
ancora meglio io ho vinto ma questo si
sapeva
se volete un altro video del genere
50.000 like esposizione mediatica e
commentare tutti così
[Applauso]
3 poteva deformano già sa sta cosa che
mi ci fa fare il bagno o plotter occhi
non cugina l'ha vegliata
sii buono ti sei fatta perdonare a ruolo
che va bene senza totale